below our ordered pairs that represent
the first six terms of two given
patterns the first value in each pair is
the term from pattern a and the second
value is a term from pattern B in the
answer box there are different
statements about the two patterns choose
all correct statements so let's think
about what's going on here they said the
first term is pattern a so pattern a the
first so the first term in each of these
coordinates is pattern a or in each
pairs pattern a so pattern a goes from 1
to 2 to 4 to 8 to 16 to 32 so it looks
like pattern a to go from the first term
to the second term we multiplied by 2 we
multiplied multiplied by 2 and then go
from the second to the third term we
also multiplied by 2 and we just keep we
just keep multiplying by 2 multiplied by
2 and we just keep doing that 8 times 2
is 16 16 times 2 is 32 now let's think
about what's going on with pattern B
pattern B so pattern B is the second
number in each of these in each of these
pairs and it's just always 3 so there's
a couple of ways to think about you
could just say pattern B is always 3 you
could say pattern B starts at 3 and
we're just adding 0 every time or you
could say that pattern B starts at 3 and
we are multiplying by 1 every time
either of those would give you would
give you just three showing up over and
over again over and over again so now
that we've looked at these pairs which
show the corresponding terms for pattern
a and pattern B let's look at the
choices here and see which of these
apply in pattern a you can get from any
term to the next by multiplying by a
constant number well that looks right we
go from the first term the second term
by multiplying by 2 then we multiply by
2 again I go to the third term then we
keep multiplying by 2 so that constant
number that we're multiplying by to get
to the next term is 2 so this looks
right the next pair should be 52 comma 3
so let's think about this if we keep
doubling for pattern a so this is going
to be times 2 32 times 2 is 64 and
then if we'd say that this is one times
the previous term we're just going to
get a three again so it should be 64
comma three should be the next one they
say the next pair should be fifty two
comma three so that's not right if we
graph the pairs the points will be on
the same line so let's think about that
a little bit let's think about that so
this is my vertical axis this is my
horizontal axis on the horizontal axis I
will graph pattern a and on my vertical
axis I will graph pattern B pattern B
and let's see pattern a pattern a goes
all the way up to 32 so I'm going to try
my best here so let's say that this is
32 then half of that is going to be 16
half of that is going to be 8 half of
that is going to be for half of that
it's going to be 2 and half of that is
going to be 1 so these are all the
points on pattern a but for any of them
the corresponding term on pattern B is 3
so we have when pattern a is 1 pattern B
is 3 1 3 when pattern a is 2 pattern B
is 3 when pattern a is 4 pattern B is 3
when pattern a is 8 pattern B is 3 when
pattern 8 is 16 pattern this is like a
time when pattern a is 16 pattern B is 3
when pattern a is 32 pattern B is 3 and
you see they all sit on a line they all
sit on the line they all sit on this
horizontal line at least the way that
we've drawn it they all sit on this line
that you probably can't see in yellow so
let me do it in this red color they all
sit on this line right over here so this
looks right if we graph the pairs the
points will be on the same line so I'll
go with that one in pattern B you can
get from any term to the next by
multiplying by a constant number well
yeah even though every term is the same
term but you can get from a 3 to a 3 by
always multiplying by 1 1 is a constant
number so we're just multiplying every
term by 1 so that also seems
to be right so all of these are right
except the second one the next pair
isn't fifty two comma three it's going
to be 64 comma three